just seeing what's up man no you excited
to go to phoenix
yeah i'm chilling you just gonna see
your family mm-hmm
she's gonna chill with the fam the white
folks the black folks
you see both do they get along do you
ever bring them together right
do they know each other yeah is that the
plot of a funny holiday movie i don't
write this one like that oh
called squirrel is that a great i would
never
oh
i would never write anything like that
i'm not saying you have to write it i
could yeah
you're not reading this yeah just
talking about [ __ ]
you ain't helping them out all right all
the [ __ ] [ __ ] you put it
right
no man couldn't do it but yeah they all
know each other they're all cool but
that's not what we asked yeah i'd love
to get them together
oh have you ever brought them together
like that oh you said they know each
other i'm saying do they get along
you know what the the first time i ever
performed in arizona mm-hmm
they came yeah they were all there they
sit on separate sides or
is it like divorced parents like my
parents like i do shows
end of september and denver my parents
either because they're divorced so they
come to
separate shows like my mom come to the
early morning late and if they do come
the same show
like my dad's in front my mom's in the
back oh through oh no
they do not see each other no it's not
like that at all no no it's never weird
no
because i'm cool as [ __ ] that's why yeah
that's what's up like
i don't bring like weird i'm pretty cool
too but they just don't get along you
know there's a lot of
yeah but they don't have a history of
not getting along my son drew this
when my dad was in town last week uh he
was mad at something i don't know some
you know kid some stupid so he drew he's
really into drawing right now so he drew
a picture
of me with a happy face i mean i guess
it looked like me then me with like a
mad
sad face he's like this is you right now
you should try and go more over here wow
he might hit you with the [ __ ]
visuals
i started laughing and my dad goes you
know it's funny he did the same thing
and
like everybody's around i'm like i think
he goes yeah at his age when me and your
mom were getting a divorce
you drew me as the devil and then
with the smiley face oh my god i was
like
that's not the same pull that up that is
super dark that is
super dark and also very sad hashtag
trauma yeah also
very sad we should probably talk to a
therapist about it
yo you as a devil he's like and then you
do you in the corner with like tears out
of your eyes i'm like
not the same damn he drew this because i
didn't give him a piece of candy
this is super deep and we should
probably talk about somewhere else
yo your dad caught me off guard when i
first met him he gave me that old the
way he shook my hand
yeah i did not expect we recreated real
quick
and then didn't he say like thug life or
something he said he thug life something
like that yeah
it really caught me off guard because i
went in with the normal like hey just
you know
that's a respectful shake i know like
his best
yeah he said it was like come on in
let's do this i told him you met him
yeah first time i ever met that's right
did he whisper black lives matter to you
the first time in denver he was in the
green room he's like damn man you like
chilling
i was like what is happening now he's
not telling my favorite collard greens
i was like hey dad i think we've had
enough
he's our amazing before i go favorite
hot sauce
it just caught me off guard i would have
done it you know like but i just didn't
know he was that's what he was going for
i was just like oh nice to meet you
it looked normal
oh it's so much fun if they if they eat
chitlins it was horrible
it was well it's like that i think it
was the you said he had
a bunch of black friends yeah but it's
like one step away from saying like you
like watermelon
you eat fried chicken yeah like it's not
quite there did you see that uh
that guy i think it was in ikea for that
uh june 19th
you know he decided to sell it junete
to celebrate it he was giving out free
fried chicken and watermelon
but it was a white guy doing it didn't
go over well yeah
yeah it didn't go over well can't be
doing that just didn't read the room
right now probably coming from a good
place yeah it's coming from a good place
but it's like
yeah yeah it's a little just
condescending yeah you know you're not
fully racist at least condescending